twood dimensional gel electroforesis is
a process by which two parameters are
used for optimal separation of the
protein the First Dimension is the
isoelectric point and the second
dimension is molecular weight so let's
say we have a sdsp gel here if we look
at a band maybe this is a band
corresponding to 75 kilal protein but
along with this protein of interest
there are many other proteins mixed up
which cannot be separated using this
method so in case of 2D electroforesis
the proteins are first separated on
based on their pH so the proteins are
focused with u pH gradient this is how
the scrambled proteins look like they
are scattered all over and when you
apply the uh current in a pH gradient
they would align thems according to
their isoelectric points and now this
block is placed on a gel and the gel is
ran the separation is much better right
now and this is how a typical gel look
like then further mpect